this yes is the start of a new chapter
for the race
what does it mean for you for it to be
held here in the Gulf this is a really
big step you know for the motorsport in
in the Middle East and to have one of
the best race and the motorsport you
know and the difficult race you know to
have it here in Saudi Arabia now so what
does it mean for you to defend the title
so close to home and to be the first one
to win it in the Middle East to to to
defend the title it's is not easy you
know because we need to prepare a lot
you know but this year we win all the
race will which we compete you know and
and our level really very very strong
you know we need to understand you know
Dakar Rally it's 2012 thousand kilometer
it's not one day out two days or three
days you know it's a 12 days you know
but we have experience and we try to do
our best and we try to do to manage and
to to be one of the strong and two to
win this race because it's it will be
dream also for me to win for first time
here in in our region did you have
second thoughts about taking part in the
rally because of the blockade imposed on
Qatar by Saudi Arabia you're travelling
as one of the official delegation of
organizers like how concerned are you
that you're going to be facing any
issues okay the politics side you know
it's between two country it's it's a
little bad situation you know but okay
from sports side this year if we see the
the team of Saudi is was competing here
in Qatar and also the team of Qatar al
said this was competing in Saudi you
know from a sports side I think it's
everything's going very very well you
know and I feel really good to be in
Saudi because I I receive a lot of
message you know a lot of welcome you
know from from the people because I a
long time I was competing there two
times and I win and really I have a
strong name you know in Saudi and yeah I
think it will be no problems you said
that Qatar will host the start of the
event in the coming years when do you
see this happening and what does it mean
for the motorsport and what does it mean
for Qatar itself for motorsports it's
mean a lot you know for our region I
hope you know the situation will be
better you know for in the future
between Qatar and Saudi you know to have
also a part of Dakar in Qatar it will be
really a great feeling you know for me
because I win three times you know and I
have really a strong name in Dakar and I
think it will be great moment and great
thing for motorsport to have Dakar also
here in Qatar why not this edition we'll
see a new terrain for the drivers what
challenges does it pose for all of them
we know Dakar is a difficult difficult
race it's dangerous you know and is not
easy but we we love you know the
adventure you know 13 women have entered
what does it say about the event I think
it's mean a lot for motorsport you know
to see the woman's you know in
motorsport competing try you know we
don't forget you know 2001 Dakar winner
it was a utak lachemann there's a lady
it's woman you know why not you know
today is making
one of our womans you know to to to to
win Decker here in our region how
confident are you of winning the race
and who do you think will be your
biggest challenger we have a stronger
confidence and I don't have really any
problem you know because I I got to
enjoy you know my race and we need to
respect all the the driver you know the
skiff and Carlos there is local driver
he has he dodged he also some other
driver yes or say Dan yeah there is a
few few names but I'm the best